i don't know that there is anyone who
could disagree with socialist ideology
what about the people in cuba right now
you both
have killed so many people
i couldn't be more proud of you david
harbour
who is do you remember him he was the
guy on stranger things
he's he's a big lib he gave a uh an
award speech
a few years ago where he not not so
subtly was attacking conservatives this
was after trump won
and said that he was going to punch
people in the face do you remember this
as we act in the continuing narrative of
stranger things
we 1983 midwesterners will repel bullies
we will shelter freaks and outcasts
those who have no homes
we will get past the lies we will hunt
monsters and when we are at a loss
amidst the hypocrisy
and the casual violence of certain
individuals and institutions we will
as per chief jim hopper punch some
people in the face
when they seek to destroy the
disenfranchised
and the marginalized yeah political
violence
we are going to physically harm our
political opponents
because that's what we do in our
democracy that's
that's right no civility no legal
processes
we're just gonna punch them so that we
don't become like the fascists
what a dope so this guy this guy that
was a few years ago he comes out now and
he says
quote this is an interview just a few
days ago
i don't know that there is anyone who
could disagree with socialist ideology
i wish this was a print interview if it
were a video interview i wish you
could hear me i don't know anyone who
could disagree with socialism he says i
don't know anyone who can disagree with
socialist ideology
if you work at starbucks and you make
the coffee then you should own it you're
the one making the coffee okay so hold
on i
just uh we don't we don't have time on
this show to dispel
the this theory of of property ownership
that if you
in any way interact with some piece of
property that then you own the property
what about the guy who grew the beans
what about the guy who transported the
beans what about the guy who roasted the
beans what about the guy who built the
starbucks what about the guy who
produced the cups what about the guy who
produced the little sleeve for the cup
what about the person who is ringing up
the customer
what about the person who laid out the
capital to start the whole thing in the
first place whether it's the farm or the
starbucks
he doesn't have much of an answer for
that he doesn't know much about anything
his first point is the most ridiculous i
don't know anyone who could disagree
with socialist ideology what about the
people in cuba right now
because you rich hollywood guy
living in america you seem to love
socialism in theory
the people living under socialism in
cuba hate it
in practice and their symbol by the way
of protest
is the american flag they've been waving
it in the streets of havana they put it
on their bicycles they sew it onto their
genes
i saw it firsthand when i when i visited
here
the american flag is called a symbol of
oppression and hatred
there it's a symbol of freedom against
the communist
tyranny but they lie to us
hey you we're not allowed to talk so
much on youtube anymore they don't like
some of the things we say
so you've got to make sure that you ring
that bell and you subscribe
because sometimes people do that but
they still don't get the notification so
make sure you do that head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
you can subscribe
to the michael knowles show and you can
order right now
my book the number one national
best-selling
non-new york times listed because
they're a bunch of jerks speechless
controlling words controlling minds
we'll see you next time
you